dans la cour du CHU de Reims le
personnel soignant se fige
une minute de silence à la mémoire de
Karen maisino en homme pénètre dans le
vestiaire du CHU de Reims hier il
agresse au couteau une infirmière et une
secrétaire médicale agresseur très vite
arrêté à 59 ans il souffre de troubles
psychologiques sévères déjà connu de la
justice pour violence aggravée il avait
poignardé en 2017 quatre personnes dans
un centre d'aide sociale c'est d'abord
avoir une pensée pour les familles pour
les proches pour les soignants bien
entendu de cet hôpital pour tous ceux
qui sont
intervenus sur ce sur ce drame et d'une
façon générale pour l'ensemble des
soignants c'est un homme de 59 ans qui
n'était pas patient du CHU de Reims qui
était pris en charge par l'autre
structure dans le département de la
marque des sous curatelle à Reims
exprime également ensemble notre
reconnaissance à tous les agents du
service public qui œuvrent au quotidien
avec un dévouement ex au service des
citoyens et de l'intérêt général selon
nos informations il dit aux policiers
avoir été maltraités dans les milieux
psychiatriques et vouloir se venger il
affirme qu'à chaque fois qu'il croisera
une blouse blanche je cite il la
plantera qu'il est bénéficié en juin
2022 du nord de non-lieu pour une
responsabilité pénale rester sans suite
et surtout le fait que ce drame ne soit
pas le premier dans notre pays tout cela
doit nous alerter sur une forme de
tolérance de l'État qui s'est installé
au détriment de la sécurité de nos
soignants c'est dans ce contexte qui est
publié le chiffre des violences envers
les médecins il est en forte hausse plus
23% en 2022 par rapport à 2021
1244 incidents ont été déclarés c'est du
jamais vu
des propos
curieux semblent-ils c'est une personne
qui a des lourds antécédents
psychiatriques pour autant l'enquête
diligentée par le procureur de la
République est en cours ils ont une
cause importante dans la montée de la
violence qu'on évoquée dans l'insécurité
la psychiatrie et aujourd'hui le parent
pauvre de de la médecine de l'hôpital il
faut reprendre en main ces secteurs
Grégoire Morano a été arrêté ce matin
par une compagnie de CRS après un
accident sur l'autoroute l'homme de 32
ans aurait percuté le pare-choc d'un
point lourd et tenté de prendre la fuite
juste après si on regarde à vue il a été
contrôlé positif à la cocaïne la
question c'est qui croit encore
aujourd'hui dans la sincérité de
l'état-major de LR
parce que ils avaient l'occasion de
faire tomber le gouvernement en votant
la motion de censure ils ne l'ont pas
fait oui il y a trop d'immigrés
aujourd'hui en France par rapport à
notre capacité
d'assimilation de ces étrangers voilà
notre pays n'a plus la capacité
d'assimiler aux valeurs de la République
ces étrangers farine Le Pen qui
présentait mot pour mot ce que propose
les LR aujourd'hui que nous proposions
pendant l'appréhension et contre lequel
pendant toute la campagne prisoncé ils
nous ont dit que c'était pas crédible il
réalisables pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ont
fait voter Emmanuel Macron au second
tour l'élection présidentielle donc et
je remets pas en cause la Convention
européenne des droits de l'homme je dis
que nous devons pouvoir en matière
migratoire reprendre le cours de notre
destin l'État a repris 98% du contrôle
de DS et le 8 juin l'état aura 100% du
contrôle d'EDF ça va nous permettre de
produire davantage de réaliser dans les
meilleures conditions possibles et
réacteurs et donc d'avoir un prix qui
soit le plus bas possible c'est bien ça
l'objectifs
à 1 euro cette offre a été lancée il y a
quelques jours par le réseau de train
low cost de la SNCF à l'occasion de son
anniversaire ces fameux billets étaient
disponibles ce matin à partir de 7
heures mais la désillusion a frappé de
nombreux usagers
on est tous pétriques contradiction mais
peu d'entre nous vivons une dissonance
aussi énorme car ilonford à 20h55 si on
ne se bouge pas le cul maintenant on va
perdre cette planète à 20h57 j'ai
plusieurs avions j'adore voler et je
dois partir donc sur la plateforme
impossibilité d'effectuer un paiement
certains mettent même en doute la parole
de la société ferroviaire et parle d'une
mauvaise blague ou de publicité
mensongère face aux nombreuses plaintes
ouigo vient d'annoncer la remise en
vente de 10000 nouveaux billets facile
de donner des leçons quand on a passé sa
vie à cramer la planète avec son avion
privé dit Teddy bar on a trouvé la
Marion Cotillard américain ça c'est pas
très gentil